dude you know what I was watching on the
way over here yeah I know what you're
thinking yes I do watch youtube videos
in my car
yeah well yeah I mean of course no I
wasn't a hack kind of had it you know
just like listening to the audio so yeah
like a punk was Logan Paul's Flat Earth
documentary which just dropped yeah dude
yeah hot off the press this [ __ ] yeah
and I don't know if it came out today or
yesterday or whatever but someone like
that senate's it yesterday okay so
someone sent it to me and was like yo
you should watch this blah blah blah and
so I pulled the tweet and it says it
says here it is my Flat Earth
documentary like the internet will never
be the same
yeah it's like dude nobody asked for
this you can't pretend like something
like this is as impactful as it is when
nobody asked for some degree of
anticipation for you to really like rock
the internet or like the world you know
yeah literally it's just you being like
oh I should go make a documentary about
flat-earthers
that that's like doing a documentary
about like [ __ ] vac saying you're
kids yeah well I thought one knows it's
[ __ ] it doesn't cause autism but I
thought it was a mockumentary is it a
mockumentary yeah like I thought this
would've ended up being like it was like
him like basically baiting everyone into
believing that he's a flat good all this
[ __ ] okay yeah good good it's just like
I'm like this is a 45-minute set up for
a really bad joke yeah it's just a goofy
bit yeah I don't think it's a good bit
yeah I mean I don't know man
to put that much effort into it then it
kind of becomes no because he doesn't
have a good bit it's not a good big as
you don't really own it
mmm he just said all he said was I think
I'm a flat earther and then he just took
a bunch of clothes with people being
like man Logan Paul's a [ __ ] and then
that's it like he didn't like he didn't
really own it and double down on it and
really take people to the bank with it
like that to me then would have been a
good bit you know like yeah if he was if
he like did a vlog where he's talking
about the earth is flat and everyone
goes you got young impressionable kids
watching your content Logan
and blue there and he does it again and
then he's like oh I [ __ ] pranked
y'all then I think would have been good
but just to be like flat earther and
that's it I don't know like a little
more effort fair enough
yeah see this is what happens when you
watch me for twenty seconds all right
but I remember like the first one of the
first lines is conspiracy theories
conspiracy theories we've all heard them
I was like yeah Logan high school essay
weighted conspiracy theories we've all
heard them
yeah then like but what about the people
that believe them yeah yeah Bigfoot area
51 my area is this the 90s who's talking
about area 51 now did you know it's
Jones yeah well no I mean you hear that
as a kid growing up yeah yeah but you
know I don't think you hear that now no
I haven't heard that term in a long time
when it aliens you know that to me it
was just that's how that's how Hollywood
got us on Independence Day what if he
made a movie about area 51 conspiracy
theories we've all heard that that's
true
that's actually true though we have all
heard them damn Logan's on some real
[ __ ] no one trusts the government why
would they they don't always get it
right yeah man they don't that's
actually you know now that I think about
it like that
damn they they don't tell us everything
[ __ ] this guy I stood with the
stretch cut he's calling he's calling
out the big [ __ ] yeah there's some other
dumb YouTube oh wait real quick
speaking of controversy hmm everyone I
didn't realize how many Melly fans we
had okay yeah what was the deal it's
everyone goes oh well he has split
personality shows um yeah but no that
part is scary okay or weird he's
basically just schizophrenic in plain
sight I don't really think he is maybe
it's his fans like trying to find a
and why he would kill two people yeah
like people dismissing the [ __ ] that in
interviews his ex ex did well like what
like after the [ __ ] like just claiming
his girlfriend faked everything you know
I mean there's got everything I don't
think people talk about if what I've
seen is not anyone being like oh it's an
excuse it's more like as someone should
have looked at this have been like yo
this kid needs [ __ ] help like he's
just in interviews this one creeped me
out like they go oh you got multiple
personalities like multiple
personalities came up he's like yeah I
got some and they're like you do
and then this girl's like tell us about
him she's like he's like I can only tell
you about three cuz the other like he
kind of starts like articulating why he
can't talk about the other personality
so it doesn't seem like a kid buu thing
where he's like I got cloned know it
seems like real this seems to split to
me yeah it's like this kid very easily
could have been schizophrenic and there
were multiple instances where he
publicly says something [ __ ] weird
and everyone in the room is like like
what like what if it just kind of seems
unrelated like or he'll kind of you know
say like yeah my split personality
Melvin you know he just be coming out
and people say what yeah everyone every
time it happens everyone in the room is
like that's not really related you like
it's his you could tell there's a stale
air that's like uh okay so this isn't
like a NAS it's just not like oh when I
get drunk no Robin comes out oh no no no
no it's not like that at all I'm
picturing him in a room I'm laughing at
schizophrenia but like him in a room
with like three other people that are
like yeah let's get wasted dude [ __ ]
Oh Nelly's coming out tonight well
depends you know depends how [ __ ] up I
get cuz if we're lucky
Melvin might come out tonight and you
know Mel Vee always trying to scare
somebody
yeah dude so I guess he killed his
friends before murder on my mind came
out yeah yeah okay yeah oh no no it was
whatever I read that to someone it was
book no is inverted okay
he made this song and then he did it so
it was like the song was not related to
like his actions kind of thing right
we're still like I'm thinking about
murder
it's not like I'm thinking about the
murder that I did it's more I'm thinking
about my future my the one I might do
yeah okay so I'm wrong about this foot
personality [ __ ] this really is a cuz I
just read a couple comments where it was
like people on like ready and [ __ ] being
like well actually you know I'll have
you know that ynw Melly actually has
like a split personality disorder and
I'm like these are just fans making up
some stupid [ __ ] just like justified in
their own mind like why this person
would do bad things
no I think it's to me that would I guys
people saying like you know this dude
the whole time what like needed medical
help and like nobody would everyone's
just like yo this [ __ ] is why yeah but
he's like yeah Melvin is fire this dude
should come out more often
no no he's sick yeah I know [ __ ] sick
I [ __ ] no I [ __ ] with all of the dudes
in this one yeah whatever the [ __ ] he's
got more of it dude [ __ ] bangs dude I
love this song cuz it's like Y&W on the
verse but then Melvin comes out on the
course I'm saying cuz it's like hardest
[ __ ] and you know meld is really about
it right
you know Melvin's about it yeah oh my
god yeah his last name is demons bro
demons yeah no yeah Melvin demons dude
oh wait his that's a split personality
isn't his government name but then Wales
by melt think yeah I don't know hmm yeah
well I mean hey conspiracy theories
we've all heard you've all heard of them
we've all you have it's crazy how life
is like that man we've all heard these
things flicks
trying to flex and I'm holding half this
Bank I'm trying to flex not trying to
flex take your fish in ocean break
that's not a flex